for today's mission which will be
entering very shortly
right out brief the centaur logs has gas
indications
all day night one
ld network ldm1
md network md zone one proceed
okay the team reviewed the arb that was
held to
discuss this issue we did today
again violate the four percent of the
trd however the arb did give
justification for
um up to eight percent of o2 two percent
h2 we are within those limits and we
recommend proceeding
lc concurs ld ld concur
empty md concurs
lc stuff 800 all secondary becomes
verified on our
link t minus six mana
copy two two phone three two three
good copy
atlas lo2 at flight level roger
rclc network first thing is coordinating
at0 2232.
copy two two three two zero zero zero
inward
t minus five on us
lc locks two go sent
okay we just heard the launch director
direct the launch conductor to set up
for a new t0
of 5 32 p.m
eastern time we will make that
adjustment when the clocks enter the
built-in hold here in just a few moments
about 30 seconds from now
t-minus four minutes and holding this is
a program 15-minute hold
lc switch to not ready
alc please separate new t-0
of 22 clone 32's open roger
and the team has now entered that final
built-in hold
the alc will be assistant launching
doctor will be
setting the clocks for the new t0 as
directed by the leadership team
this is
lcalc countdown clock has been set for a
new t0
of 22 colon 32 zilla roger
lcrc1 rc ranges approved two two
three zero zero t zero
that was two two three two that's good
copying
by team our clocks are set we have an
approved t0 of 22
at 32
currently approaching l minus 17.
and as you just heard launch conductor
scott barney verifying the team is now
realigned to the new t0 of 2232
zulu time which equates to 5 32 pm
eastern time that puts us at
just over 17 minutes prior to liftoff
the next major milestone will be the
terminal count status check and that
will be occurring in about 10 minutes
[Music]
as i mentioned earlier today's launch is
ula's 29th for the nro
let's take a look at the huge role the
nro plays in the security of our country
[Music]
we are the agency that made the
impossible possible
protected the world and brought
technology to levels undreamt of
the race to space was a series of firsts
and we were there we were the first
to surveil our adversaries from the high
ground of space
literally taking technology to new
heights
watching our adversaries guarding
against the threat of
nuclear war and providing strategic
advantage to our nation we were the
agency no one had heard of
because we worked in total secrecy
but we've stepped out of the shadows and
we
are writing the next chapters of
american space technology
we are the national reconnaissance
office the nro
the world leader in our tradecraft
collecting top secret imagery and
signals from space
natural disasters threaten thousands of
lives
conflicts displace millions and
adversaries mouth threats
we give advance warning aid in the
aftermath
protect our citizens and safeguard the
world
we are the only agency that develops
these tools
partnering with the intelligence
community the military
and the best of private industry to
drive
innovation we are the leader in space
intelligence systems
the nro at the heart of it
our people people who take satellites
from
idea to orbit focusing talent and
resources
developing building launching
operating sophisticated nro systems that
help us
maintain global vigilance 24 7
365.
small sets made possible by
miniaturization
reducing costs and expanding
possibilities
large satellites with capabilities
designed to
answer our toughest national security
questions
pioneering achievements on the ground
where analysts
bring it all together how do we do it
by investing in the latest research and
development
using augmentation automation
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
employing acquisition strategies to
encourage competition
enabling us to work with the industry's
best and brightest
like-minded people committed to
technology without
limits
this is where careers rise to heights
unimagined
where you can take your eyes and ears
into space
we deliver under budget and on schedule
meeting and exceeding expectations
to answer questions yet unasked we
develop new technologies
every day and put them to use in record
time
in the high ground of space no one can
match us
the national reconnaissance office the
world leader in
intelligence gathering we are the nro
lc fuel 2 go pl2
first step 860 centaur lh2 at flight
level
roger lc pne 2
go step 760 centaur lh2
fbv cycle tests are complete roger
l minus 11 minutes
all right team this is lc on net one we
are complete through operations
for operation 50 picking up an operation
60
and working for the phone
all communications switch to channel one
all personnel and visitors
remain in present position until launch
maintain operational silence in the lcc
terminal count briefing if a condition
exceeds a launch constraint
any time after the terminal count status
check the observer should announce
hold hold hold on channel one identify
the station
and briefly state the reason for the
hold
flight control perform launch on time
verification
roger osm
place srb ignition sna switch in the
enable position
and you're coming away from that one srb
ignition enabled
roger lockstew verify cisa first flow
flowing g2 to the gisa verified
osm verify the fco rco and osm all fire
switches are in the process
in a few moments launch conductor scott
barney will pull the launch team for the
final go to pick up the countdown
29 engineers and managers are pulled for
system status and readiness to proceed
this is the final status check for all s
vehicle systems ground systems
spacecraft and the u.s space force
eastern range
the vehicle system readiness poll
includes electrical systems hydraulics
pneumatics propulsion systems flight
control and propellants
let's listen in as scott barney performs
the final polling here in about 30
seconds
lc switch to the ready position all
steps are complete prior to the status
check
no minus eight minutes
and my apologies we are now about 30
seconds away from that final
that final status check occurring
status check to proceed with terminal
count respond go no go
atlas systems propulsion go hydraulics
go pneumatics go lo2 go
water go centaur systems propulsion
go pneumatics go lo2
go lh2 go has gas
go electrical systems airborne go
ground go facility all right fps
go flight control go gcq
go gcq
go
gc cube network uh go
roger operation support go com
go envelopes go ecs
go redline monitor go quality go
op safety manager go ela safety office
go vehicle system engineer go and online
go range coordinator clear to proceed
launch direct launch vehicle is ready to
launch
mission director you have permission to
launch
proceeding with the count alc verify t0
is set
for 22.32 verified
polling is complete the ula launch team
and the nro mission director are go for
launch
from t-minus four minutes until launch
you'll be listening to scott barney and
his team performing the final steps in
the countdown
hear the team call out that a topping
has been secured followed about a minute
later by the callout for transferring
the atlas and centaur stages from ground
facility power to internal battery power
at t-minus 155 the team will command the
launch sequencer to start followed
shortly by securing the centaur liquid
hydrogen and
centaur liquid oxygen topping activities
at t-minus 140 the team will command the
flight control system to launch enable
and arm the flight termination system
in the final minute atlas tanks will be
verified at flight pressures followed by
a verification of centaur tank pressures
a final status check of atlas centaur
and inner oil 101 readiness is conducted
at t minus 25 seconds
at t minus 3 seconds the rd-180 engine
will roar to life
after liftoff you'll hear the voice of
rob kesselman providing launch vehicle
ascent data
copy
not here you're on that one
this is atlas mission control at t minus
four minutes and holding we anticipate
releasing the hold in just a few moments
on my mark the time will be t minus four
minutes and counting
three two one mark
the countdown clock has resumed and we
are go for launch at 5 32 p.m eastern
time
t minus three minutes securing
lo2 topping atlas thanks to flight
pressure
250
fps internal
the atlas tanks are now pressurizing for
flight and the flight termination system
is on internal power
okay
159
vehicle internal 155
launch sequencers start 150
securing centaur lh2 securing centaur
lo2
140 launch enabled
137
fps armed
120 goes to use arm
fcs count started 115
reduce ecs for launch roger
110 then valve lock
t-minus one minute rock report range
status
range green the launch vehicle payload
ground systems and eastern range are all
go for launch
t minus 40 seconds table that's step
three
28 yes reduced for launch roger
25 status check go atlas go
centaur go nrol 101
with that call the nro 101 mission is
ready to launch
t minus ten nine nine eight eight
seven six five four
three atlas ignition two
one zero and liftoff lift
off to the atlas nrl 101 mission for the
national reconnaissance office
you are hearing the voice of rob
kesselman providing launch vehicle
ascent data
control alex has now completed his
pre-programmed pick-over maneuver
now with 28 seconds into flight out is
two miles in altitude going at
1200 miles per hour
already 180 he'll throttle down slightly
as expected engine response looks good
already past mach 1
engine pump speeds and injector pressure
are in family for this level
srps look good
party 180 has throttled back up as
planned
lock two
now 70 seconds into flight atlas is 10
miles in altitude
5.9 miles an altitude
2100 miles plus
standing by for srv burnout
yeah burn out on all three srps standing
by for jettison
180 is now throttling down slightly and
we have
citizen on all three srvs
okay all personnel net one start system
securing for operations
that's not past mach 5
approximately two minutes remain in the
atlas booster phase of flight
this time booster tank pressures look
good
and booster battery voltages remain in
their expected range
party 180 continues to operate as
expected
since our reaction control system is now
pressurizing to flight level
we are now three minutes into flight on
the l-101 mission atlas is now
66 miles in altitude 125 miles downrange
traveling at 7 500 miles per hour
we're now throttling down in preparation
for payload fairing jettison
and we've had successful payload fairing
jettison and successful cflr
load deck
i was just throttling back up after the
separation event
atlas has reached a 4.6 acceleration
limit
though they look the same this evening's
atlas 5 rocket lifted off with new solid
rocket boosters
program leads jamie m shed and samantha
suarez recently sat down to discuss the
new srbs
let's take a look hi i'm jamie umscheid
i am the vehicle systems engineer for
vulcan centaur program at united launch
alliance
prior to this role i was the integration
lead for the gen 63 program
with me today is samantha suarez systems
engineer and integrator
together we led the integration program
for the gen 63 on atlas 5.
nro l101 will be the first mission to
fly those srbs
under a strategic partnership northrop
grumman was chosen to be the sole
provider of solid rocket boosters
to united launch alliance for our family
of rockets it's a lower cost
alternative to the srvs that have been
flying on atlas v since 2003.
so one of the interesting parts or
challenging parts of integrating these
motors is
you have to be able to swap out the srb
and make sure you're not increasing risk
to the atlas launch vehicle
and additionally that you're meeting
system performance requirements
the main thing was setting a really
strong requirements foundation
working with our system level teams and
ensuring that we
flowed system level requirements down to
the design requirements and that the
supplier built to those
also understanding with those
requirements which ones
did have some flexibility so that when
we you know ran into challenges as we
were developing these motors we could
react appropriately
and understanding verification of those
requirements northrop grumman would go
through incremental design
phases for the motors they started with
a system requirements review then
progressed into preliminary and critical
design reviews
every step of the way our government
customer was a partner in that process
once you get through your design phases
then you get to go do the fun part
test so there's a lot of different
phases of testing so you'll have some
early on development testing for like
proof of concept
you get into component specific stuff
for the srb itself there's two major
tests
structural and performance structural we
did what was called
super proof where you pressurize the
case
and you apply loads on it and ensure
that the case functions
as intended when it's under load then
you have static fire
which is how you validate the
performance of the motor
staticfire is unique uh for solids in
that with an srb you don't get to fire
it before you fly it so the qual is
crucial after the flight of l101 um
we will actually be transitioning the
atlas 5 over to gem 63's after 2021.
same year 2021 we're going to be flying
the first
vulcan centaur and vulcan centaur will
use the larger more powerful variant of
the motor the gem 63 xl
flying the gem 63 first on atlas gives
us an opportunity to have more
confidence in that first flight of
vulcan centaur
it also allows us to reduce the the cost
of the atlas 5 and make it more
competitive in the launch market
i was on the program for four years and
i don't know about you but i'm pretty
excited
i am so excited and i know we're not the
only ones there's a ton of people from
ula
uh northrop folks and the u.s government
that were all
key contributors to this program and i'm
definitely ready to see it fly
my thanks to rob kessimon for his
participation in today's broadcast
stay updated with the mission on ula's
live blog at ula launch dot com or join
the conversation on social media
before we sign off we'll take you to
another look at liftoff which occurred
at 5 32 pm eastern time
i'm dylan rice on behalf of the ua
launch team thanks for joining us and
have a great evening
with that call the nro 101 mission is
ready to launch
t-minus ten nine nine eight
seven six five four
three atlas ignition two
one zero and liftoff lift
off the atlas nrol 101 mission for the
national reconnaissance office
you are hearing the voice of rob
kesselman providing launch vehicle
ascent theta
roll maneuver
party 180 closes engine control
alex has now completed his
pre-programmed pitch over maneuver
now at 28 seconds into flight out is
two miles in altitude going at
1200 miles per hour
party 180 has throttled down slightly as
expected engine response was good
r20 clock pass mach 1
engine pump speeds and injector
pressures are in family for this
level srps look good
rd180 has throttled back up as planned
lock two
now 70 seconds into flight atlas is 10
miles in altitude
5.9 miles in altitude
2100 miles plus
alice has passed mock three
standing by for srv burnout
we have burnout on all three srbs
standing by for jettison
the r180 is now throttling down slightly
and we have
citizen on all three srp
my
you